well the health minister jillian keegan
joins me now um it's a question we put
to a minister yesterday but does the
government know how many people are
currently self-isolating
well we don't actually collect that data
on a daily basis but it's obvious if you
look at how many people tested positive
yesterday's about 215 000 that they'll
all be self-isolated and obviously from
the previous days so it's about a
million people probably are
self-isolating right now
isn't this a figure that you should know
though it seems that you're you're
working on a load of assumptions and
guesses
no you get we get the tested positive
and obviously we get those figures so
you can add those up over the days but
obviously what we don't know is how many
people after day six and day seven
have tested negative and then are free
to leave isolation so it's it's around
about a million people though
okay and
now announced tomorrow by the prime
minister a hundred thousand tests for
critical workers how are they going to
be distributed
they will be distributed directly to the
workplaces of those critical workers so
some of it will be via some hubs that
they've set up but they are being
distributed so it's a separate channel
separately uh directly to those
workplaces
it seems quite a low figure 100 000 how
did you come up with that
well they've worked with the sector to
look at those absolutely critical
workers um and what we'll be doing is
delivering a daily test a test every day
so they'll have packs which will uh mean
that every day that they're they're
they're going to work they'll be able to
take that test but of course we also
have a
mass testing available we're one of the
uh well i think we're testing more per
head than any other country through the
usual channels as well and we actually
had a record for home deliveries
yesterday as well with 741 000 testing
kits that were sent to people's homes
yesterday so you know there are other
channels as well and lots of workers use
those but for nhs social care schools
and also now for this uh critical worker
channels we have separate channels
um who which sectors are actually going
to fall into this category then because
we we spoke to the road haulage
association and they haven't been
contacted by the government they have no
idea obviously lorry drivers are pretty
critical aren't they are they going to
be included
it's um fire police emergency services i
think border force testing lab staff
obviously they're quite critical at the
moment
food processing and some elements of
transport but not everybody in transport
would be
considered
critical and would need to have this
daily test delivered to them every day
why not i mean surely lori lorry drivers
are pretty critical
well because they can get tests very um
easily actually most people the main
channel for most people is to get tests
via um the the main channels either uh
booking uh to get something sent to your
home or pharmacies and i know there's
been a couple of surges in demand which
have meant that we have had um you know
a couple of times when they haven't been
available but we have ordered a lot of
tests and we have 350 million which will
be available in january and february
we've actually tripled our lateral flow
testing capacity that's one of the
things we've been working on over the
christmas break
there has been a real issue haven't
there i mean i you know anecdotally
there are people who have have tested
positive and are now waiting to go back
to work but they can't because they
can't get
the lateral flow test delivered to their
homes we know as you say these figures
about all these large numbers that are
being produced and shipped out but some
schools are reporting a two-week delay
in receiving kits it's certainly not
going smoothly at the moment is it in
terms of getting it into people's homes
right now
well it's obviously difficult because of
the surge in demand and as i say we're
testing more per head than any other
country in the world but we did have a
record day yesterday uh 741 000 and we
are tripling capacity for january and
february so hopefully that should ease
up some of these sort of short-term uh
difficulties we've had but you know if
you go on and you continue to go on the
website which i know is a bit of a pain
but if you do go back on
you will find that more come available
within the day and as i say a record day
yesterday 741 000 kits were delivered to
people's homes
what about the weight for results as
well we know that that has been an issue
the home care association says that some
care workers are waiting over a week for
pcr test results so they can't come back
to work mencap has reported an eight day
wait for some of its employees
what is the cause of this delay in the
pcr results
it's all surge in demand actually is
what's what's caused some of this i mean
obviously you talked about some of the
numbers with omicron i mean the massive
number of people coming forward at once
actually to get those so we have also
looked to increase our pcr capacity as
well
but really it has been a surge in demand
we are dealing with unprecedented
numbers and obviously we're getting back
as soon as we possibly can um but as i
say we've set up a testing system which
is you know one of one of the most
comprehensive in the world
the pcr you're saying we're setting back
up did it close down over the christmas
new year period
no no no i said we've we've increased
capacity
we're increasing capacity in the labs in
the pcr labs it doesn't close down at
all now
because the health workers and care
workers are meant to be prioritized
aren't they
yes they are prioritized they have a
separate channel and they are
prioritized both for lateral flow tests
and for pcr tests
why is it taking so long then you know
if the prioritized people are taking
over a week
it doesn't sort of give much hope for
the rest of us
i think that's typical actually i mean
you will find some people are waiting
too long and that's why we've worked on
increasing their capacity but that's not
typical you wouldn't normally expect to
wait a week for a pcr test response and
actually now more and more um the
capacity will be being increased and you
know we as i say having more and more
lateral flow tests as well which people
are using before they go out or before
they go to work or before they go and
meet family elderly relatives so they
are
being used very very widely
and despite all of this
the nhs seems to be overwhelmed at the
moment we've got a number of trusts with
critical care status the northeast
ambulance service has been reportedly
telling some of its call handlers to
tell people
to just bring people in if they think
they're having a heart attack friends or
family instead of calling for an
ambulance the royal college of nursing
has spoken about the fact that this is
not hysteria it's blowing the whistle uh
on the situation uh nhs confederation
says that the government's saying that
we're coping we're managing it doesn't
chime with the experience of the staff
is the government giving a very
different message than we're hearing
grass roots from those working in the
health service
no i think what it's important for for
you and your viewers to understand is
those
local
measures
where somebody
says they're in a critical state they
are actually part of the local
contingency planning and there's a lot
of different levels to the contingency
plan including
restricting some services for a period
of time as well which you've seen one or
two of the hospitals have decided to do
and what that acts as is the start of an
escalation process which then calls in
mutual aid calls in additional staff so
they work with the local resilience
forums they work with their nhs regional
staff to then put in place measures to
help with that situation and that's part
of the contingency planning and actually
that happens every winter these are very
tried and tested plans and it does
asking people to take their neighbors to
hospital we know that they're going to
be under extreme pressure we know that
what about the nhs
northeast ambulance service saying to
people that you're not going to get an
ambulance just get your neighbor to
bring you in if you think you're having
a heart attack
well that is that is not uh not what we
uh what we have put in place at all so
we have more ambulance crews in
operation than we've ever had uh we also
gave 55 million pounds extra just for
this period to
cover staff and make sure that we had
increases in staff and staff in levels
and i've actually asked nhs england to
look at that particular case because
that doesn't sound to me like that is
that's that's an acceptable approach
people should be able to get an
ambulance if they have a heart attack
and that's why we put that extra funding
in place to make and that's why we've
been building up our ambulance service
over the last couple of years
the prime minister yesterday talked
about riding out this this latest wave
of covert and it's clear from the data
that that omicron isn't as serious in
terms of mortality outcomes that than
other strains like delta were um but
there is of course the impact of long
covert and we're now seeing obviously
it's taken a while for this data to come
forward analysis from america penn
state's researchers found that more than
half of those who had covered 19
still had symptoms six months later so
do you think the government needs to
perhaps take a step back and think again
about its policy in that sense yes
large numbers of the population may not
die
but could large numbers of the
population be affected in the long term
and this could be an issue that we're
storing up for the nhs in months and
years to come
well you hit on a conundrum jane there
which is could it so we have actually
got to act on the data that we have and
that's the decision that we've made this
time the most important thing that we've
done is to build up this booster program
to make sure that everybody can get
access to a booster as soon as possible
so if i could just use the time to urge
everybody who hasn't to please come
forward for one of those two million
appointments this week if you haven't
already had one but of course one
there's been many things we haven't
known we didn't know at the beginning
the severity of the data of the of the
disease and now we've we've had some
good news on that of course we don't
know um
about this particular strain and the
impacts uh longer term we do know a bit
about long coverage which is why we've
set up some long coverage clinics and we
are very concerned to make sure that we
uh obviously take care of people who
have long coverage it is debilitating
but you know there's there's so many
unknowns that all we can do is act on
the data that we have because we have to
be balanced and proportionate we know it
is not easy to lock down a country we
know it comes with costs and
consequences to lives to livelihoods to
life chances for children it isn't an
easy decision it's not one to be taken
lightly and that's the balanced and
proportionate approach that we've taken
but it has to we have to act on the data
we have
on the data on boosters as you did bring
them up
why are there are still nine million
people in the uk that haven't had their
boosters and i know that you're
keen to bang on about about all the the
availability of boosters but but only
less than 20 000 people took up that
offer on saturday just gone um yes you
had some days in december with big
numbers but it's fallen off a cliff
since then why have people stopped
getting their booster do you think and
why isn't the government doing more to
get them in
well we are obviously we have a big big
program of
of booster programme all across the
country so it's very convenient it's
very easy to get your booster um well i
think there's probably a little bit of a
bank holiday lag obviously we're all
just back now to work and school but
there is also probably another factor
that i know in my own case there's some
people who are still having to wait out
their 28 days because they actually have
had covered as well so i would expect
those people there was a big surge of
people that had covered during december
and over christmas period so they'll
have to wait 28 days so i suspect that's
probably also having an impact on some
people's ability to get the job straight
away but we would urge everybody if
you're eligible if you are within that
28 days if you've had covered please
come forward and please come forward the
quicker we can get everybody boosted the
better we can really be prepared to what
to ride that wave that the prime
minister talked about it's one of the
key parts of our defense our wall of
defense and we're really relying on this
as a national mission for everybody to
come forward please to get their booster
or if they haven't yet been vaccinated
to come forward and get their jab we
know they work and they make a massive
difference